[Music]
so if you're doing attorney Monday it's
not bad okay so let's look at it I know
for my Kazushi his fine has to tilt and
then another line has to go okay what
you've been shown so far is how to do
that correctly okay so we do I'm on me
he's pushing you I have to blend little
push
thank you guys to push and I started
[Music]
okay so now all i gotta do is finally
Steven I'm in there so until you see oh
oh there it is do one side
so he'll pull it's like I throw the
ball to myself so I don't do any turn
he's going around me
don't evening
same thing I don't pay enough / yes the
pivot on the foot that I pimped okay so
when I'm in that front foot that's where
he pivots oh so same thing it's not a
tip you can you see like the duck hey
it's time I tell you again to do
gymnastics on me neither
okay it's Mike just my dog so I go to
yield and pin them foot see that so
we're gonna do that first time he pushes
my yield hole
here's an evening I just turned right
when you turn it off
I followed or you say that it's not it
when you do it
that's plain okay so if I do that and
you try to grab my head because I never
tilted okay so this boy he comes in with
a grappler to put up pick it up like
you're gonna well I can't hold him up so
if you pay attention he's not going like
this then takes the ball but he's not
doing that 50p right thing either this
did you see that I just tilt the spine
right here tilted right here that foot
hasn't come around yet if that thought
came around that's not gonna work you
gotta fight you it's the same thing the
uneven are you
the leg is going forward forward then
the ticket if the leg is going back
you're not gonna work okay so what I'm
you technique then that leg is still
forward you see that you get up okay try
down
dropping him not pulling the thread
I turned inside the script and now I
have his farm in the barn don't pull his
hand then turn them inside in there
we do that movement
I'm moving this floor okay so he's gonna
want to not fall upwards then he's gonna
try and hit that foot there to get it so
that's where the newer I have to change
yeah puts the foot there kazoo she's now
in a different place okay but I have to
first pressing with this fool
so I keep not doing that little duck
walk around me
and then he does she got nothing because
he's gonna want to turn go ahead he has
a Turner
you see it'll not out here and I do some
gymnastics now standing still okay he's
rising with this and boom now I'm gonna
show you it does not always foul by
keeping it going
you see if I do the parallel
[Music]
you see they're holding okay so that's
your drill now whoa keep it going
okay that bro is taking the place of the
neck crank for the position time
all right so after I need this skill all
right till now everything is the same so
I slide up to the C grip I'll just have
not the farm there's no leverage they're
stronger people just yank it out okay so
you're going to slide up to the grip
right there and it's torquey whoa down
he goes
then Kokomo so don't grab here
I cheated wolves and during their home
is in danger fight
don't confuse the micro drill with the
technique okay so when I did I showed
you the Kazushi it's kind of a noggin
wasa you know I'm projecting away and
this one is Oh Silas so I don't project
away the circle we come here I did this
technique this angle right has to keep
going around around around and then it's
his residual energy that creates the
exponent begin it safe in here he has to
keep going around me
whoa don't throw away he keeps going
around me ends up underneath me okay
otherwise he pulls me that's how you
gonna rip his arm off because then
you're gonna lose the throw okay but I
micro micro adjusting
[Music]